another chaotic chapter in the fight for
control of Venezuela's Parliament while
a government-backed deputy tried to show
that he was in charge outside opposition
leader Huang wide door again four of
soldiers attempting to prevent him from
entering the National Assembly this time
he and some 90 opposition deputies
succeeded in pushing their way into the
chamber as the previous group fled the
building to the leader of the majority
opposition faction of parliament
reclaiming his seat as Speaker of the
House for however long was an important
symbolic victory this is proof of what
is possible when we are united organized
and determined determination Venezuela
determination but the opposition may be
overstating its victory what's obvious
is the President Nicolas Maduro could
have employed far more force as he did
on Sunday to prevent Kwon guardo and his
deputies from entering this legislative
palace the government of course will
argue that the opposition has every
right to take its seats in the chamber
but just as ordinary deputies not as the
leaders of Parliament but there's likely
a more strategic objective to regain
control of the only institution not
under module command probably Midori
will say that all these spectacles
between warring factions proved that
Venezuela needs new parliamentary
elections why because he knows that if
he doesn't give the opposition in
transparent conditions for a free
election which is unlikely an important
percentage will boycott the poll so his
party will win control
but why doe is hoping that this latest
escalation of the political conflict
will reignite sluggish popular support
for his leadership
he's calling now on Venezuelans to again
take to the streets to demand regime
change and to believe that this time it
will make a difference see in human al
Jazeera Caracas